oh my god he will not let it go
you could tell he's latin because land
people are tenacious
my name is nick borrelli and i'm
traveling the country to sit down with
some of the biggest latinx artists in
places that are meaning to them and help
tell their stories we'll talk about
their journeys and careers and explore
issues of identity culture
discrimination and representation this
is scene
[Music]
good morning welcome to my uh hotel room
i am in new york city uh flew across the
country from l.a we are on our way to
meet john leguizamo not only is he
having a huge impact on multiple
platforms but he also touched my life in
a personal way when i got to see his uh
his one-man show as a teenager and and
really felt seen for the first time also
we're gonna give the man his flowers
it's been three decades that he's been
doing it on broadway on film and tv and
now writing a comic book so uh the man
does it all and he does it with humor
and i'm just really excited about what
we're gonna get to do today so let's go
[Music]
so
[Music]
late
nick myself nice to meet you guys how
are you doing what took you so long i'm
sorry you're in traffic yeah the air
traffic sucks
we're going downstairs to my man cave
where the craziness happens
it's a beautiful home you have oh thank
you but you said to everybody you meet
though
oh wow
i feel like i'm in a college professor
about to get in trouble
now nick
we called you into the office because
we've heard rumors about you
they're all true please share them i'm
ready to take down notes i want to learn
from you so what you did that and then
what'd you do
i want to take it back before we even
start the interview sure because you
actually played a key role in my life
how's that uh when i was a senior in
high school in berkeley my girlfriend at
the time was like i want to go see this
this show that's coming to sellerbach
hall and i was like i can't afford
seller brokers oh it's expensive she's
like oh if we're the ushers we'll get
into the show for free she had a whole
system yeah i was like all right let's
go and it was it was freak i didn't
really know what i was getting into but
i remember
sitting down and just from the start of
your show and this is me as a senior in
high school was the first time that i
really felt seen it was the first time i
was like wow there's somebody here who's
got one foot in hip hop one foot in
latin culture who's going through
all these different things with her
parents with with immigration because
i'm a first generation immigrant it was
really the first time where i saw myself
on stage on tv on something
and and really felt like okay i'm not
going through this alone
and that was the first time that i was
like oh maybe i could do something in
media maybe i could do something to
represent the journey that i'm going
through and all the people are going
through the things that i'm going
through well that's incredible because
that's
what i wanted to do in my work i wanted
to reach people who were like me kids
that were like me that felt unseen un
unwanted
that you didn't matter you didn't count
and it was because you have to fight
that every day that sense of i can't do
this
this this place is not
geared for me so you know i wanted i
wanted to shake that up and go yes you
can every one of us can
i always like to kind of start
interviews by setting the tone the way
that the intro sequence in the movie was
so if we take it back to jackson heights
to your childhood home that intro
sequence like pans into your childhood
home what are we seeing what are we
hearing what are we smelling yeah so
you're going through jackson heights and
you're coming down
into the planet and then you see a
subway pass by and when the subway
clears you keep going through and
there's our apartment on the fourth
floor 4a uh on deadman street
and uh it was a cul-de-sac right next to
the subway so i would watch a lot of tv
and maybe this is why i learned partly
how to write was because i'd be watching
like dan august or something where they
go we just got the killer
and the train would come like
and you would see this
and that's who the murderer was and i
was like what
so i just have to try to piece it all
together in my head and then you would
see my mom cooking i mean who knows
pig's feet garbanzos
you know rice were the sounds that were
emanating from the streets at that time
yeah it sounds where kids playing
yelling music music at the time was
always salsa or or some r b and and then
you know up rock dancing was it was huge
at all all the community centers after
school and then when hip-hop came you
know all my friends who were like
incredible breakdancing which i couldn't
you know i'd go home and you know you
practice in your room and you want to go
what are you doing in there you're
breaking the walls you know you're just
throwing yourself around trying to grab
a move but all you're doing is just
bashing against the walls talk a little
bit about having that energy growing up
i read that you actually got into acting
kind of by getting into trouble at
school can you take us back to that time
you know i was like a class cut up kind
of like a problematic child i was a the
poster child for a troubled kid the
school made me go go to therapy because
they wouldn't let me back unless i had
therapy which
i hated at the moment but then now you
know it saved my life
but one of my friends indio suggested
like you know when we come and deal the
number seven train and you get on the
mic it was like an open mic he made up
his own open mic night on the subway so
we kicked the conductor's booth open and
then i grabbed the mic and i started you
know just dude
do you know my voice i'll get olive oil
cups meatballs
i said boy i say boy you're a chicken
hog boy over the speaker for the whole
yeah wow and i kept going and going and
singing songs and whatever how did you
go from that to actual having acting
classes well my math teacher mrs zuffa
would tell me you know instead of you
know mr la squeezamo instead of wrecking
the class you know they can make penalty
moldy bread they can make something out
of you why don't you take your whatever
it is that you do and become a comedian
so
it was like the first person i said oh
wow i could maybe do something with this
and he was a mentor you know mr zuffa
was a mentor you need like when you come
from from
the neighborhoods that we come from
you need somebody outside of you to tell
you
that you can that you're worthy so i
needed that several times so yeah i
found an acting school civility showcase
theater and i went there and uh this
little old lady who looked sounds like
katherine hepburn was like oh so good to
have you
and then i you know i said yo what's up
lady what do you do is he's like oh your
accent is horrific we're going to have
to do something you'll never work with
that sound what's up lady why not and
you know so she gave me she sold me like
hundreds of dollars worth of like
dialect classes so she was making a buck
off my back but you know that's why it
sounds so incredible today so uh you
can't tell where i'm from you thought i
was from england didn't you
yes why are you laughing like that no
because i i i i heard the same thing
like i originally want to be a sports
broadcaster and uh and people were like
you'll never be a sports broadcaster you
got a thick accent like that's not oh
and you have a you know you slow down
your speech and sometimes and they're
like you'd never be a sport broadcaster
how crazy is that because that's the
sound that i want to hear
i'm like where are the latinx
sportscasters i want to hear those
sounds yeah i was talking a couple
friends recently we're doing a movie and
there were three latin people in it
which was like a miracle because it's
i'm always the only one or and they're
the only ones this one actress had a
much thicker accent because she's
younger so she's had less time to work
on it but i go i love your sound you
know i love rosie president sound i love
dasha polanco's sound you know i i love
those those the way that the language
moves and the diphthongs is stretched
out and
a little bit of urban a little latino in
it it's such a beautiful sound yep once
you started to act did that feel like a
way
to just work through some of that energy
i think it's a combination of things i
mean definitely
in that acting class the teacher was
brilliant actually and she gave me dino
this book it's about a teenager who's
having troubles at home with his hates
his father and he was arrested and and
is in therapy and it was like oh wait
check check check check so when i did it
was like like an epiphany but that's
when i realized oh my god i can do this
this is the only thing i want to do i
don't want to i don't care if i'm famous
or successful or rich i just want to do
this thing and then i think there's a
couple years before you get to nyu what
are what are those years like and is
that when you're working at kfc kfc was
paying for my acting classes because her
uh addiction classes and diction tapes
were mad expensive so yeah i i you know
i worked there for two years
at the time square kfc i saw things that
no young man should ever see walk me
through that period in your life i mean
you're working at kfc
you're acting you're going to school
yeah like what was that time like we see
now we see all the awards you see this
amazing office you have but it's like
i'm sure there's somebody watching who
was probably in those shoes when you
were at that time figuring how am i
going to make it out of this job and
to start my career you know i was
failing in high school but i was doing
the acting classes i was in therapy
and then you know uh reality hit i was
like oh my god i got to apply for
colleges my grade point was terrible and
uh
i i got
i got sharp and i was like i got to i
got to fix myself i got to fix my life
what inspired you to ponatas working at
kentucky fried chicken you know i just
saw i'm not i did it all i was cooked i
was cashier i did the catering i did it
all i go this is gonna be the rest of my
life i don't i don't want that to be me
i want to have something and then i
couldn't get into nyu at first i had to
go i had to go to cw post which actually
ended up being the most education i ever
got in my entire life with those two
years i spent a tw post and then i
transferred to nyu because that was the
the best acting program that i thought
it
existed in america here i am in nyu
a student
i had fixed my accident a lot by this
point and all the white kids in my class
were going to five auditions a day
i was going to one every five months
and i was like wait a minute i'm working
as hard as they are i got better grades
and then i realized oh my god i don't
have the same opportunities as they have
and i realized
i know i realized that it was it was it
wasn't an equal playing field you know
it just was never going to be i mean you
know this illusion you're a young man
and you realize oh my god life is not
fair
because just because of how i look
how i sound
my economic class that i come from it's
just not a fair playing field no matter
how talented you are it doesn't matter
and but i thought talent
was equalized
it was the great equalizer and so the
audition that i would go to every five
months was always for a drug dealer a
murderer a killer
or or somebody your gardener or somebody
servicing your house and it was like
wait a minute i worked this hard to be
playing those kind of roles i started
doing improv and other things because i
was like you know this
work working towards hollywood which was
really highly wouldn't
was not gonna be the place so i try to
find other ways other avenues
and uh i started finding theater
off-broadway theater and performance art
and performance art was the place that i
found my freedom was that your way of
just showing hollywood your own worth
through your own eyes not through their
eyes yes yes writing became my way
to
for me as an artist to be my full self
and how i saw myself not how hollywood
or network tv
saw me
because look right now the census came
out the 2020s and said we're 20 almost
20 of the population
and then a couple years ago we were only
three percent of the faces in front of
the camera less than one percent of the
stories less than 100 of the crew less
than one percent of the executives
that's cultural apartheid
and the same thing goes for politics you
know less than one percent of elected
officials and forget about publication
latin children are at least seen in
children's picture books so right then
there your self-esteem as a child is
already being challenged
think about that
marinate on that i'll be right back
thank you for joining us in my podcast
with nick and john
people who might not be of the culture
might not fully understand the full
impact of that right because
that not only
affects our self-esteem it also affects
how
people who don't interact with us on a
daily basis see us then they don't
necessarily think about our positive
contributions to this country right so
not only are we invisible but when we
are seen it's a negative portrayal you
said in an interview it was in 94 it was
on pbs and you said that most of the
roles that you were up for were
stereotypical and were one-dimensional
and you were just asking to have
three-dimensional characters yeah who
could actually lead a movie and not just
be
supporting right how do you create how
do you create a latin star
in america when the roles are
one-dimensional and and not worthy of
awards
the ugly question is why aren't land
people succeeding what's the ugly
question are we not smart enough not
talented enough not good looking enough
not hard working enough no none of those
stereotypes and racist ideas because
nobody tries harder with less access a
friend of mine i won't say her name
uh years ago when i was doing mobile
miles sent out her resume dar skin latin
woman sent out her her resume with a
picture one with the latin name her real
name and then one with a white wi-fi
name the wi-fi got call backs
the latin one got nothing
that's that's just a name just off the
name exactly and that's
just explains the whole situation right
then and there you made that statement
in 94
were
you know almost 30 years later
do you feel like things have changed yes
yes things have changed incrementally
unfortunately 40 years i've been in this
business
and i guess we went from one percent to
maybe this year i think we're going to
be at four or five percent
in front of the camera i'm not sure what
what the numbers are behind
i mean things are improving i think
i think covet
made us really look at ourselves in
america i think black lives matter was
huge awakening for america a reboot for
america to look at themselves and see
what's going on
i think everybody's trying to do the
right thing and hire
many more people of color
i mean what i want to see i want to see
20
of the of the roles in front of the
camera of the crew
of the stories of the executives we're
25 of the u.s box office yeah one in
four and and and we have three percent
of the faces i'm not asking for extra i
just want
what what's do us
i mean i i've seen the development
process through all my life at every
studio new line universal fox
searchlight they work on scripts for
years and years polishing them making it
better and half of those die and then
half of them make it to the screen we
need to be in that pipeline they need to
be taking
latin scripts and working them that hard
so by the time they get to this point
they're the best that can be yeah but it
just takes somebody who looks like me
being an executive and saying that
story's worth it because i've been
pitching stories for 30 years always
thinking that my writing
was falling short because they never got
green lit so i was like damn i thought
it was a good script but then i'm
winning awards on broadway and
off-broadway obi awards and drama desk
awards for my writing and
and a tony tony nominations and even
emmys
but never getting my movies done
and you know there was always excuses
were you know why latin people don't
want to see latin people i'm like no
then who do i want to see for christmas
at my house
some norwegian family said i want to see
latin people is what i want to see
or they would tell me like when critical
thinking i i directed they would tell me
latin people don't want to see feel good
movies no no we want to see really
depressing suicidal flicks that's that's
the actual conversation the actual
actual things
that that would come out right
it's hollywood wisdom you know
there is an audience in a hunger so i
know that exists regardless of what a
studio head or a network says to me
anymore i know hamilton would have never
got made at a studio or a network
they would have been i'm sorry lynn i'm
sorry but uh wait a minute burr is gonna
be black and and and hamilton's gonna be
puerto rican i'm so sorry i didn't mean
to laugh but uh i i can assure you they
didn't speak in hip-hop back in the
1700s the founding father it would have
never got made never
but why did but theater
they're no gatekeepers you just got to
raise that money and get a good review
and and and now you got the biggest
masterpiece that brother has ever seen
i have a bunch more questions but how do
you want to space it between here and
the restaurant oh he's hungry that's his
segue that's his
subtle way of saying i'm hungry
[Music]
because your stomach was crumbling when
it take you to lunch yeah this is your
one of your favorites one of my favorite
spots that margarita is a killer
down here i mean i used to go see a lot
of theater and perform that's what you
asked me about where did i perform it
was yup i did my performance heart at
ps122 a converted school
gusto house dixon place the kitchen
knitting factory all these little spots
like you had like 20 people maybe
in the in the audience do you remember
that first time that you hit the stage
what that feeling was like oh my god it
was incredible i was doing a one-man
piece it was a one-man show about if
latin people had written the bible
you know jesus and mary and all latinos
you know
loud and boisterous and fun
and and the crowd loved it and it was
amazing it's like it was my first
full-length piece that i wrote and
performed by myself playing all the
characters are you nervous or well hell
yeah if you're not nervous then you're
not then it's not really you're not
really risking anything
here we are this is my spot right here
oh nice
you have your vax card yep
hey how you doing how's it going how are
you
how about a little mescal a little come
down what are you drinking oaxacan
express
yeah
well here comes his lunch
to walk express thank you thank you
thank you brother appreciate it a meal
replacement here we go cheers cheers
brothers
to you to you to all the doors you've
opened
and the glass ceiling that keeps i got
scars in my head from hitting that glass
ceiling luckily i'm hardheaded so i
don't really feel it i feel like we have
to be in this in this industry just to
be able to make it past all the the nose
yes talk about that a little bit because
i feel like you hear so many no's that
like it's hard i don't care how hard
your your your skin is yeah at some
point you start to internalize that like
how do you maneuver through the industry
and all the nose well it's interesting
because you know the rule is you you
become a celebrity you get a certain
amount of success
you don't talk about
your problems you don't talk about the
difficulties you act like oh
it was it was a magic carpet ride you
know i feel like it's really important
to talk about all the problems
and all the difficulties especially if
you're a a person of color especially if
you're latinx there's a lot of people
struggling
and and we need to change things and
spike lee showed me because he's one of
the first who spoke out against hashtag
hollywood so white well he was a hashtag
oscar so white but i wasn't sure
if you're yeah
okay so let's be real so he he brought
that out and i was like yeah i went
right and started retweeting him like
crazy and then i posted
oscar so white but hashtag hollywood's
even whiter
you know there's colorism within latin
culture that we have to fix but there's
colorism in hollywood too i mean i
benefited from being light-skinned and
and i stayed out of the sun so i could
work wow i i definitely would not go in
the sun for years that was so pace that
was a conscious thing oh yeah exactly
worked and uh and all the latinos that
made it so far a lot of them were all
light skinned you know what happened to
all the
afro-latino and and the majority of
indigenous latinos
they don't get a shot you know
so you know there's a lot of things we
got to deal with in hollywood and we got
it fixed and we got to speak out and we
got to speak up
and and you're doing it i mean this this
this this is such an important
space to have you know to be able to
talk about all these things you have
been
not shy
about vocalizing these things why is it
important to you and why do you think
not as many people are as vocal as you
are about this subject well being vocal
has it's it's cost it has a cause like
when i became very politically conscious
and then politically on my soch
i lost half my followers wow
and then i got a lot of hate
tweets you know go back to your country
go back to mexico which i'm i'm not
mexican but i'll gladly go back to
mexico because it's a great country
still like when i post political stuff
on facebook they go john you used to be
so entertaining now you were bored but
you know all this hate stuff
which i ignore you know i feel like if
you've achieved a certain amount of
success it's your duty to give back you
got to give back you can't be an ostrich
and stick your head in the sand and
pretend it's not happening not existing
i don't know i'm just too socially
conscious and
and i feel like
i had a fight to get here
and i've earned the scars and the wounds
and i want to talk about how i had to
fight to get here if if anybody had done
what i had done there'd be so much i
mean i got a producer to him i'm not
gonna name his name but he said you know
too bad john you're puerto rican because
you're so talented otherwise you'd be so
much further along and that wasn't an
insult it was an actual fact at the time
i didn't know how to take it but now i
know it's like yeah
because you were latin you only got to
get so far you're only going to get
certain roles you're only going to get
certain opportunities i was in a movie
for a week and then i get a call from
the director going oh john i'm sorry i
can't have you in the movie anymore i go
why what happened lose the funding no no
uh we cast this latin actress and we
can't have two latin people in the movie
because it becomes a latin movie you
know what i mean right and i'm like you
mean and i'm like i wanted to say like
what do you mean it's better no no he
meant like i can only have one token at
a time and this is recent no this was
about eight years ago okay
i mean tokenism is real
glass ceilings are real
colorblind casting was promised to me by
all the artists
in the 70s we were going to break that
down and then
it was it wasn't until hamilton 2000
somewhat
that they finally did it and it
succeeded showed that it does work take
me to
you going back to theater for latin
history for morons i want to talk about
what i imagine was probably a very
personal uh conversation between you and
your son right can you take me to that
day when he comes home from school and
he tells you that he's being bullied
like what was that conversation well
that's kind of hard especially after
having some uh mezcal i don't know i
don't i don't want to get mad emotional
on camera um
i don't i don't want to
i want to i want to keep this uh
it was a hard conversation obviously you
you you you know it's it's your beloved
child and they're being mistreated and
and uh profiled racially and ostracized
and the school didn't know how to handle
it and it was terrible um
but i wanted i i wanted to be an evolved
father i didn't want to be like my my
dad would we go you know go kikis don't
come back home till you kick his ass
that door is locked till you kick his
ass i mean i wanted to do that but i
didn't but i also wanted to be an
involved dad and i wanted to weaponize
his information and give him latin
information about our history to
strengthen him to arm him i look to his
history textbook and it's like wait a
minute there's nothing mentioning our
contributions or anything
it's like we didn't exist
so i started doing mad research and
learning so much and the crazy thing was
i was the one that was healing i was the
one that was being empowered
and then i realized oh my god i can do
this
for the 70 million latinos in america i
can do this maybe for the 500 million
speakers
in the world
you know through this work let me take
it back just just a little bit too you
go wherever you want to go
this is your show so the to the
conversation i'm not trying to i don't
want to talk about the airwaves bro i
know you don't want to get too emotional
i just want to talk a little bit more on
the personal side because it's like
everyone can turn on netflix and see the
result of it but the fact that it came
from such personal
caring from one generation to the next
generation of like i don't want you to
go through what i went through no i mean
i don't want any kid
to go through what i went through i
don't want any latin kid to go through
what i went through i don't want any
white kid black kid asian kid and for it
to be so close to home it was it was
devastating you know so i was definitely
couldn't believe that my son is having
to go through the same [ __ ]
you know
40 years later or you know that that i
went through is crazy so that
conversation happens at what point does
that instantly hit you oh my god he will
not let him go
oh my god he will not let it go you can
tell he's latin atlanta people are
tenacious
holy [ __ ]
we're going to talk about what i want to
talk about you can skirt the issue you
want but i will still get back no that's
the reporter and his mom let's let's
talk about your mom
i want to talk about your markers your
mom's incredible so there's a big
influence on you oh you don't know don't
try to skirt the issue no i'm i'm gonna
bring it back around i'm gonna tie it up
with a nice knot you brought up my mom
my mom's a professor in a good way that
would matter out of respect in an
amazing way my mom's a professor at
berkeley
she comes and stays with me it probably
was for thanksgiving or christmas i show
her latin history for morons she's like
this is amazing the next semester she
incorporates it into oh no get out of
that
yeah
that's incredible but your mom was a
huge influence for you and and and and
my mom's my hero like i didn't turn on
the tv to so there wasn't anything on tv
for me like you said there wasn't really
much for me to turn on and be like oh
this is something like my mom was my mom
my dad my best friend right person like
she wore all the hats yeah like the
single latin single mom yeah yeah yeah
my mom was a single mom too i mean i had
a dad till
i mean i still have a dad but he was at
home until
13 then my mom became a you know super
mom single mom latin mom dad so you know
yeah but we're the same flavor you know
like sort of urban street intellectuals
we're educated we made it through
college because of our single moms and
whatnot and it's a certain badge of
honor i wear that proudly yeah yeah me
too me too here's to you here's to you
again once again
[Applause]
[Music]
what's left for you to accomplish
oh so much i'd love to help the next
generation get there
their work done made produced there's so
much great talent out there i want to be
able to help them
i want to be that studio exec that that
gets that that gets their uh material
and their product greenlit the exactly
we've been needing for for a long time i
love it
to you no no you don't mean it to you
no no you you know you know you're a
narcissist come on it's all about him
this
much respect
[Music]
so we're on the way back to the hotel as
you can tell we're in a new york city
street we got jackhammers taxi cabs
people walking by probably wondering why
i'm holding a camera but uh but yeah
taking a little time to reflect on the
conversation today i think the the high
school senior in me is still freaking
out that uh that i got to meet somebody
who inspired me greatly i am thankful
for john for opening up his home and
just being thoughtful and sharing a very
vulnerable side to him i think it's
important you know we hear numbers
thrown around 70 million latinos
four percent of movie roles but i think
when you see the humanity behind it you
know when you see how it affects the sun
when you see how it affects a father
uh i think that's when it's like okay
now i understand what this conversation
is about and i'm thankful for for john
for doing that and it's cold and i'm
looking forward to the next episode so
uh thank you for tuning in and we will
see you at the next one
[Music]